hello and welcome to the server I've got
black again what's going on here
Mohamed's dorami from morocco i guess
why do I have black again yaddam modern
main line of the Petrov Bishop c4 yeah
that is the cards and variation from
cousin Cara wanna sing filled up I don't
think white is anything special here in
this line
hmm interesting way of playing this 94 I
can simply take it of course but this is
not not really what I wanted 27 is going
to be okay I think black has not yet
decided where to castle that so both
sides are possible widest normally yeah
castling long in in this in this line
[Music]
it's not quite clear if I want to cancel
short or long
this is the possibility as well yeah
let's do this first
I know it looks a bit strange for
because my bishop on f6 looks odd but
it's something that I can easily trade
Knight c5 it's not really a problem okay
going to a castle short I mean the ephod
is half open and maybe here with the
with the night I have ideas with a five
a four night c5 Queen f7 leads to rather
two problems for white I think so this
is not very worrying now I'm quite happy
this is a very okay position g4 is that
really good it looks like pre weakening
moles
so I'm stopping h4 and try to get play
against the F pawn rook f7 f8 Queen f7
Queen f3 this is also if I get dissing
that would be really noisy Queen a7
Queen f3
I don't think g4 was appropriate him
note that White's Bishop is only
fulfilling a defensive duty of covering
f2 there's just no active idea that it
has it detects absolutely nothing yeah
this is interesting trying to cut cut
the bishop away
so um Queen to h5 is the thing hmm I can
still play this though
Queen h5 is not really doing anything
I have g6 Queen age 6 97 yeah okay
into now look at five just I didn't
really see that but Quincy forecheck was
a threat yes this leads nowhere
okay um the chick
I guess there's a bit of this is lazy
chess hurt just no Queen b5 and he's got
time time issues okay okay going for
discovered attack but it's really
there's just no square
[Music]
I should
try to be somewhat quicker
mmm my bishop is unticked I can take the
whole red
my knight if my knight gets active then
I will probably win it was pretty stupid
on c6 and now is going to join didn't
want to sacrifice stuff
let's take stuff that's better with
Queens traded the time problem won't
really matter
you pre-move trickery
okay mmm that was I don't think g4 was a
good idea so let's have a look at Bishop
c4 that was Magnus's choice against
Fabiano Khurana in st. Louis in I think
it was late August I think late August
early September Corona I think played
castles my idea is to play Bishop f6 and
I should be six trading the bishop
because I think that this structure is
perfectly fine for black Kim 27 long
yeah and now if I this may be debatable
but you know it's it's a convenient
choice I did not want to do that because
I thought it's interesting I thought
white might take him I would be sixes
good yeah yeah of course mmm you know
what I forgot is that after the Czech
Queen to be several it's just going to
be trapped okay yeah okay then then I
actually prefer to cancel long maybe I
mean that wasn't a bad move I think e5
white plague Knight b3 maybe it is
stronger to take if we look at the game
the night was really silly on v3 it
never did anything yeah never really got
any activity so this is simple probably
not bad and yeah I thought this should
be roughly equal okay this is indeed a
little bit annoying but still what is my
what is the problem I can just do this
here right
a queen of three is a double attack
okay then this is a little bit
uncomfortable yeah absolutely
if I cannot play the natural queen
Giselle okay I would have taken with the
Queen because but you know this makes a
lot of sense here why not open this yeah
yeah yeah I think it's just an okay
position G for Bishop h4 yeah I don't
think G Force could understand
it's just weakens a lot o queen h5 is
losing time I want to play this anyway a
six this is a bit of a lazy move but
it's it's possible okay yeah I can
already take take what can I take
what can I think either said double
check no and not within my powers I mean
does this is good sure but of course the
other line it's better I could have
taken the pawn earlier only only here I
recognize that I can actually take it
yeah and yeah I'm probably some
inaccuracy sir but nothing serious it's
a cycle it's just a lot better for like
here I can take on c4 I saw that it if
you have eight seconds and you can get
this ending it's a good thing to do
because here and I have no weakness
everything is covered you're gonna not
go into blunder and so on it's just an
easy game simple technical tasks okay
guys thanks for watching